Speaker 1: But the DOJ may have other things that
they have in mind as well, because according to
reports out this week, the DOJ is also seeking
more surveillance footage from Mar a Lago.
Now, as we all know, the DOJ already has their
hands on some of the surveillance footage.
Speaker 2: From Mar a Lago.
Speaker 1: And in fact,
it was getting that surveillance footage that
kind of expedited the need for the FBI to go
down there and seize all these documents to begin
with. And now reports say the DOJ needs even more.
Speaker 2: They want more.
Speaker 1: And that can only mean one thing,
according to the experts. That one thing, of
course, is that they didn't get it all. That
there could be more documents hiding down there
in Mar a Lago. Or maybe. Maybe they were loaded
up and taken somewhere else so that when the FBI
showed up, some of the even worse stuff that Trump
may have stolen wasn't even on site, and they
didn't know that he had moved it. That's why
they want that surveillance footage. At least
that's the prevailing theory, honestly makes a
heck of a lot of sense. These DOJ.
Speaker 2: Investigators.
Speaker 1: Are not doing this willy nilly right.
They're not flying by the seat of their pants.
They're making sure that they have
crossed their T's, that they have dotted.
Speaker 2: Their eyes.
Speaker 1: And that they
have the evidence to back up any claim or
request that they make, because they understand
the political ramifications of going.
Speaker 2: After a former president.
Speaker 1: Especially one with a cult following
like Donald Trump, especially one whose followers
are out there right now making death.
Speaker 2: Threats against the very
people doing these investigations.
Speaker 1: And they're looking
at all that and they're looking at their
evidence and they're saying, you know what?
We need more. So for them to even think that
right now tells me they have what they believe,
I think is pretty strong evidence that
they don't have all of the evidence.
And that's a terrifying thought in and of itself.
Right. Trump could be hiding even more documents
there. There could be more than just the 700
pages of classified information. Some of it,
again, pertaining to nuclear documents. I'd say
that's a war worth a look through the footage,
right? I think that's something
maybe we ought to be looking into.
It remains to be seen, of
course. They have not officially
made the request for that extra surveillance
footage. It could be coming any day now. We have
to wait and see. And that honestly is always the
hardest part, right? Especially with Donald Trump.
We have to be patient, just like we have to be
patient with the January six hearings. We have
to be patient with the New York investigations and
then the Georgia investigation and the lawsuits
about him possibly inciting the riot, causing
the injuries to the police officers and the
Aegean Carroll defamation lawsuit, which honestly
still to me, in my opinion, is the biggest one.
Speaker 2: Out there because of
what it could prove about Donald
Trump if he ever gives that DNA sample.
Speaker 1: So there's a lot of things,
which means we got to have a lot of patience,
and that's not always easy, but that's the.
Speaker 2: Position that we are in right now.
Speaker 1: I am Ferron Cousins for more. For me,
by the way, you can follow me on YouTube at
YouTube.com, slash the Ring of Fire. You can also
follow my other YouTube channel at YouTube.com
slash. Fair and balanced. And I'm on Twitter,
Facebook and Instagram at Fair and
Balanced. This is the David Pakman
show. I'm Farron Cousins in for David
Pakman. And we'll be right back with more